My daughter doesn't like cake,
but it is her birthday in the morning
so she requested a blueberry cake
and even though I'm not a good baker,
I'm trying to make this work.
So when everyone went to bed,
I started baking. Started by making a blueberry compote and a blueberry
and then moved on to mixing all of my dry ingredients
and wet ingredients for my cake.
I combined some eggs with buttermilk,
some vanilla, avocado oil,
and some blueberry puree before whisking that all together.
Then poured my wet into my dry
and mixed it all until combined for adding some blueberry compote
and melted butter, mixing until my batter was nice and shiny.
While my oven was preheating,
I spoon it onto baking sheet and baked it for about 20 minutes.
Once it was done baking, I popped in the freezer for about an hour
before starting on my buttercream.
I whisked together some butter and cream cheese
before slowly adding some powdered sugar and blueberry compote.
After about an hour in the freezer,
I cut out some round circles.
Since I was making a four layer cake,
I spread some buttercream on it,
followed by blueberry compote,
and then I added on my next layer
and repeated that for all four layers.
Once I reached the top, I spread my blueberry buttercream all over
and tried to get it as neat as possible.
For taking some fresh blueberries and creating little clusters.
Since she is turning 4. I opted for four blueberries and four